[Applaudissements]
devant vraie voiture
bonsoir les enfants notre nounours et de
joyeuse humeur ce soir je suis toujours
je vois vue lorsque je vais voir mes
petits amis patrons m'ont le cheval hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop en
robot capable nicolas ça c'est une bonne
cachette
oh oui il nous trouvera pas
bonsoir la compagnie
il n'y a personne
je suis sûr qu'ils me font une blague
plus de petits coquins ils ne doivent
pas être cachés bien loin
[Musique]
où sont ils
les garnements ils sont sous la table
ballon sortait je vous ai vu petit
c'était bien que j'ai dit et tu nous as
pas trouvé non je ne vous ai pas trouvé
allons les petits il est tard
monsieur 90 et bien bon
avec tous les petits garçons
avec les petites îles aussi nous nous y
tu es gentil mot
dit notre chéri
au but me fait un gros plaisir
alors je vais vous dire
voilà c'est simple tout bonnement
j'adore
en font
une faute dont à lui
rend sa manière n'est ni moi nous
nourrit quand tu reviens bientôt
j'espère bien
oui nous nous serions
je viendrai
au
[Musique]
micro no-cd même bonne nuit les petits
la
j'éteins la lumière
fait pour
[Musique]
oh
bonne nuit les petits faites comme vos
amis nicolas et pimprenelle allez vite
vous coucher mais n'oubliez pas de faire
votre toilette et de bien vous l'avez
dans embrassez bien fort vos parents le
feu de boer
[Musique]
e
vous
à
encore
[Musique]